Колись у Вюнсдорфі, що за 40 кілометрів
на південь від Берліна, був розташований головний
військовий форпост СРСР у Східній Європі -
"закрите місто", куди не могли потрапити
звичайні громадяни НДР.
Це гігантська територія, на якій були
розквартировані понад 50 тисяч радянських
солдатів і офіцерів разом із їхніми сім'ями.
Ще 30 років тому у Вюнсдорфі розміщувався
штаб Західної групи військ.
Деякі радянські казарми відремонтували
і перетворили на апартаменти, однак
частина будинків усе ще чекає інвесторів.
Гарнізон перетворився на місто-привид.
Ось таким бачить майбутнє Вюнсдорфа
берлінський професор урбаністики Екарт Ган.
Він пропонує влаштувати на місці колишнього
військового гарнізону футуристичне "місто-сад",
зразково-показове поселення майбутнього.
- Ідея полягає в тому, що в Вюнсдорфі має з'явитися
екологічна модель, така собі лабораторія.
Замість солдатів у Вюнсдорфі нові покоління
могли б навчатися тому, як будувати міста майбутнього.
За нашими розрахунками, кількість студентів
може бути від 6 до 10 тисяч. Половина спудеїв
могла б приїжджати сюди з гарячих країн, які
потерпають від глобальної зміни клімату,
а друга половина - з тих країн, яким загрожує спека
і засухи в майбутньому, наприклад, із Німеччини
та інших європейських країн.
На папері все виглядає розкішно:
колишній будинок офіцерів як навчальний центр,
поруч - канали, гуртожитки, теплиці, городи, парки.
Професор Ган переконаний, що в контексті дебатів
про глобальну зміну клімату екомісто в Вюнсдорфі
могло б стати прикладом для наслідування у всьому світі.
- На міжнародному рівні вже досягнуто компромісу
щодо того, що основна причина глобальної зміни
клімату - саме сучасна міська та урбаністична політика.
Увесь світ говорить про екологічні міста -
і ніде у світі не побудовано жодного такого міста.
Вюнсдорф повинен стати саме тим місцем,
де з'явиться перше в світі інтегроване екомісто.
Утім, це в теорії. А в реальності все значно складніше.
Власник ділянок - агентство регіонального розвитку
федеральної землі Бранденбург.
Його представники налаштовані вельми скептично.
- 80 гектарів, на яких пропонується
реалізувати проєкт, - на них є також великі лісові масиви.
Ми знаємо, і це обговорювалося з місцевою владою:
змінити їхнє цільове призначення майже нереально.
Їх ніколи не можна буде забудовувати.
З одного боку, в проєкт екоміста включені ділянки,
на яких у принципі неможливе будівництво,
а з іншого - ділянки, які вже продані, тобто вони не є
на ринку нерухомості.
Колишній будинок офіцерів розвалюється на очах.
Час від часу його орендують для фотосесій
і кінозйомок,
але нового власника будівля так і не знайшла.
- Один багатий росіянин у нас уже був,
і переговори доволі успішно просувалися. А потім
за кілька днів до підписання договору у виданні
"Шпіґель" вийшла стаття про те, що його підозрюють
у відмиванні грошей, і ми відмовилися.
Адміністрація громади Цоссен, до складу якої
входить Вюнсдорф, у письмовому коментарі
називає проект екоміста "абсолютно
нереалістичним через безліч факторів".
За словами глави адміністрації, у влади вже був
украй негативний досвід із подібними гігантськими
і тому малореалістичними у втіленні проєктами.